DAVE REISFELD: Hello,
my name is Dave Reisfeld
and I'm a customer
engineer with Google Cloud.
In today's session we're going
to talk about modern content
delivery at scale.
Our agenda for today's session
is a brief introduction
about CDN's in general,
and what is Cloud CDN.
And then we're going to
talk a little bit about some
of the new features
that have recently
been released on Cloud CDN.
We're also going to talk about
some adjunct capabilities
that support Cloud
CDN and really
help provide additional
functionality
for your configurations.
And lastly, we're going
to talk a little bit
about some upcoming
platform enhancements
that we're making
to both Cloud CDN
that I think you'll be
really interested in seeing.
So we're jumping right in.
What is Cloud CDN?
So before we kind
of go there, let's
talk a little bit about
what a Content Delivery
Network is in general.
A Content Delivery Network
is a series of web servers
that are designed to deliver
content close to end users.
Generally speaking,
when customers
look to use a Content
Delivery Network,
they're really
looking to get access
to one of five key benefits.
Some performance benefit,
by serving content close
to end users.
Global reach, being able to
expand beyond their origin
infrastructure and having the
CDN give a point of presence.
High availability,
ensuring that there's
no single point of failure
in the delivery chain.
Scalability, both in terms of
vertical and horizontal scaling
for planned and
unplanned event activity.
But also from a
security standpoint,
both in terms of secure
content delivery,
but also in terms of denial of
service and security mitigation
capabilities.
So Cloud CDN is Google's
Content Delivery Network
that has been designed for
accelerating web and video
content.
The Cloud CDN platform
has been built
to support Google's
exacting needs.
What I mean by that is the
Cloud CDN platform that you
use on Google Cloud
is the same platform
that Google uses for
delivering search results,
for delivering Gmail results.
So you know that this is a
highly performant and highly
scalable Content Delivery
Network platform.
Specifically, as it
relates to Cloud CDN,
there are various
performance capabilities
that we embed into Cloud CDN.
Things, for example, like
the industry leading time
to first byte.
These are a lot of
the technical kind
of nuances that we bake
into the Cloud CDN platform
to ensure fast response
time, fast throughput time.
And a lot of that comes
around from Google innovation.
Things like Speedy, that
manifest itself as a CGP2.
We also look at
things like QUIC,
and how that is quickly morphing
into the new HTTP/3 protocol.
But you also can look at
new standards in pacing,
for example the
BBR functionality
that you can find
in Cloud CDN, that
was first developed at Google.
Global reach, the
Cloud CDN platform
consists of over 140 different
edge locations around the world
in 35 different countries.
This ensures that you can have
a point of preference anywhere
around the globe, where
your end users are located.
From a high
availability standpoint,
Google backs up our Cloud
CDN platform with an SLA.
A 99.95% availability SLA
to ensure that you always
have your content delivered
and it's always going
to be available on Cloud CDN.
In terms of scalability,
the Cloud CDN platform
is a multi terabyte per second
content delivery platform.
This is an active platform,
delivering terabytes
of data on a daily basis today.
This is not a new platform,
but this is simply
the commercial use of Google's
existing content delivery
network platform.
And lastly, from a
security standpoint,
Cloud CDN supports both PCI
and HIPAA based workloads.
You also have the ability
to customize TLS handshakes,
whether it's in terms
of specific ciphers,
or specific TLS protocols
that you want to use.
One of the highlights of
Cloud CDN is the network.
Many of you have been familiar
with the Google Data Centers
within the Cloud program.
But added to that are the
edge CDN nodes distributed
around the globe.
Some of those locations are
within Google Cloud data
centers, where you're
doing compute today.
But we're also in other
satellite locations
to extend the reach
of the platform.
Interconnecting
all of those nodes
are Google controlled Fiber.
So unlike some other
competitors in the marketplace,
Cloud CDN interconnects
all edge nodes
with Google controlled Fiber.
So when there is a cache
miss on the edge server,
you are routed your request back
to the Google origin location,
across Google controlled Fiber.
And this is a key
differentiator of Cloud CDN.
Now in our next segment that
we're going to discuss today,
I want to highlight some recent
releases of the Cloud CDN
platform.
Specifically, there are
kind of two areas of focus
that we really want to
segment content through.
There's performance
characteristics,
and there are
feature enhancements
that we've recently released.
The first feature we want
to talk about is TLS 1.3.
This was recently
released in April
of this year, where the
entire fleet has been
upgraded to support TLS 1.3.
One of the main benefits
of TLS 1.3 is it is faster.
It's about 40%
faster over TLS 1.2.
And that really translates
itself in time to first byte.
By reducing the
number of round trips
a client needs to
make with the server
in order to establish an SSL
connection, the faster we
can start delivering the
payload, the content,
that the end user
really cares about.
One of the other enhancements
that's made to TLS 1.3
is that it's removed some of
the obsolete insecure ciphers
that have been found in previous
versions of TLS 1.1 and 1.2.
Approximately 80%
plus of end users
can support TLS 1.3 today.
So in order to take
advantage of this,
there's nothing that the
end user needs to do.
Their browsers
already support it.
Cloud CDN just makes this
available as a protocol
option for the end user to
communicate with the Cloud CDN
server.
The next feature we want to
talk about is Custom Origins.
Prior to the release
of Custom Origins,
the only way for content to
be fulfilled on Cloud CDN
is through infrastructure,
through content
that's actually hosted and
domiciled on Google Cloud.
Whether that be a
storage instance,
or a compute instance.
With the introduction
of Custom Origins,
you now can attach
third party origins
that are not part of
your Google Cloud tenant,
in order to have that be
delivered by Cloud CDN.
So this now gives
you the ability
to extend the life of your
existing origin infrastructure
and still support Cloud CDN.
This also can be useful as
part of a migration strategy.
As you move content
into Google Cloud,
you can use Cloud
CDN as a bridge
to kind of up your
origin infrastructure,
migrate your infrastructure
into Google Cloud,
and then change the
pointer of the backend.
So this becomes a huge
enabler for not only
Cloud CDN, but also as part of
a content migration strategy.
The other thing to kind of point
out here as a differentiator
is with the Custom Origins.
We support not only
HTTP, HTTPS 1.1,
but we also support HTTP/2.
So while the end user
client to the Cloud CDN Edge
can support HTTP/2, many other
content delivery providers
downgrade the protocol from the
edge talking back to an origin.
With Custom Origins,
you have the ability
to maintain the HTTP
protocol from edge
all the way to the origin.
So you can take
advantage of head of line
blocking and multiplexing
capabilities of the HTTP/2
protocol.
From an integration perspective,
something to be cognizant of
is with these third
party origins,
they still must be
publicly available.
So you can't use an RFC 1918
private IP address for this.
It still must be a publicly
available IP address.
Subsequently, you also--
that web server also
needs to be an HTTP
oriented web server,
whether it's HTTP or HTTPS in
terms of its protocol exposure.
So you can't use any UDP
style protocol there.
The next feature I
want to highlight,
that was recently enhanced
to the Cloud CDN platform,
is along the lines
of access control.
Now prior to the release
of signed cookies,
we always could've support
query strings as a way
to mitigate content access,
and to help prevent the hyper
distribution of content.
We've now introduced the
ability to support sign cookies.
So not only can you use query
strings or sign cookies,
you can actually
use them together
as a way to provide more
comprehensive content
protection strategy.
Generally speaking
though, if you
think of how the Access
Control works today,
there are three core
elements to be cognizant of.
There's epic time,
this is the time
of the expiration
of the URI asset.
There's the key, by default
Google can support up
to three keys simultaneously.
And you can rotate those keys
at will through your Cloud CDN
configuration.
And lastly, there's
the hashed value
that you use to create that
secure token value based
on the key and the URI path
that you want to incorporate
as part of the security check.
All three things need to be
present as part of your Access
Control to prevent the hyper
distribution of the URL.
Now one of the things that's
unique about Cloud CDN
is that there are other
ancillary functions
within Google Cloud that
actively support the Cloud CDN
service.
So if you think about how
Cloud CDN comes to life,
it leans on these
other capabilities
of the wider portfolio
to enhance the offering.
In this portion
of our discussion,
I want to kind of highlight a
couple of those new features
that were recently
released that provide
additional functionality to
the Cloud CDN user experience.
The first feature we
want to talk about
is redirects and rewrites.
And this particular function
is an extension of the Google
Global Load Balancer.
Today we now have the ability
to perform redirects and URL
modifications.
Prior to this, you had to do
any sort of rewrites or URL
modifications on your
origin infrastructure.
With this new release, the
Google Global Load Balancer
has the ability to
dynamically do the rewrites,
or redirections.
We see this quite often
in terms of use cases
for things like HTTP
to HTTPS modifications.
We also see this as part of a
URL shortener strategy, where
you might have a short
friendly URI path for marketing
purposes, but behind
the scenes you
want to explode the
URL to actually point
to the actual
origin destination.
The next feature we want to
talk about as a highlight
and extension to Cloud
CDN is on logging.
More specifically,
there are two edge cases
that we want to highlight here.
Number one is the
edge cache status.
Prior to this release,
the Cloud CDN platform
never exposed the behavior
of the edge cache.
Whether or not we
served it from cache,
or we had to fetch
that from the origin.
With this latest enhancement,
we now expose this information
to you in the log line.
So you now have the ability
to see whether or not
the actual edge cache served it
from its own stores, or disk,
or if we had to fetch
it from the origin.
This can be important in
helping you figure out
your optimized content
offload strategy.
And so you can set
alerts, you can
set monitoring against
these data attributes
in the logline to help
improve your offload rates.
The other enhancement
that was recently
released inside the
loglines is the IATA code
of the Google Cloud CDN edge
server that did the delivery.
The IATA code is a
three character code
that sometimes is
referred to as the airport
code of where that Google
Cloud CDN edge server actually
resides.
So the idea behind this is, you
have some visibility as to how
Google is actually delivering
your content to end users.
Now mind you, this is not
the actual destination
of where the end
user is located.
This is merely the
edge server that
was used to fulfill that
specific edge request.
The next feature I want to
highlight here is Cloud Armor.
We've recently now enabled Cloud
Armor to work with the Cloud
CDN origin infrastructure.
For those of you that are not
familiar with Cloud Armor,
Cloud Armor is Google's
inline security offering
for WAF and network
layer protection.
And this is designed to
help protect origin compute
resources.
Specifically,
within Cloud Armor,
it supports OWASP
ModSecurity rules,
but it also supports IP
white listing/ blacklisting,
as well as country level IP
whitelisting/ blacklisting.
The benefit of using both
Cloud Armor and the Cloud CDN
platform together, is it
gives you fantastic volumetric
protection.
But it also provides
presentation layer protection,
such that you can now
protect origin workloads
and deflect requests that have
been detected by the security
rules, or your IP or country
list blocking schema,
so that your origins don't need
to deal with those requests
that we know are basically
of malicious intent.
The other benefit of working
with Cloud Armor and the Cloud
CDN platform together is that
the messaging for Cloud Armor
is directly embedded within
Google Load Balancer loglines.
So with both of these
solutions in place,
you'll have a single
source of truth
where you have
visibility in terms
of what is allowed or denied.
And if we denied or
allowed a request,
you can see the policy rule from
Cloud Armor that specifically
was being enforced in order to
effect that specific logline
request.
Now we'd like to turn a little
bit into the second half
of the year.
What are we intending to bring
to market within Cloud CDN?
The first feature
I want to highlight
is Flexible Cache Control.
Within Flexible
Cache Control, there
are three core capabilities
that fall under this umbrella.
There is Cache Control,
there's Header Manipulation,
and there's Error Handling.
As we talk about Cache Control
before the Flexible Cache
Control release, Cache
Control header values
need to be dictated by
your origin web server.
And many customers
have complained
that that was not
how they wanted
to control the cache setup.
With the Flexible
Cache Control release,
the Cloud CDN platform
now will have the ability
to apply cache control rules
on CDN platform itself.
This will help improve
the cache offload rates
by you no longer having to
manipulate your origin web
server.
But it also simplifies
the workflow process
where the CDN automatically
will apply the rules,
rather than you
having to be more
specific about your work and
path and header manipulation
within your web
server configuration.
Specifically from an
integration standpoint,
we will have three
main setting options.
So we will still maintain
origin cache control values,
and that still will
be available to you.
But we're going to add
two new capabilities
for being able to serve cached
objects, for static objects,
as well as the ability to
just simply cache everything.
Where in this case, we will
ignore whatever decoration
the origin is supplying in terms
of cache control header values,
whether it's private,
public, et cetera,
and we'll just apply our
own TTL setting values based
on your configuration set.
In the case where you're
using cached static objects
mode of operation,
what we will do
is we will apply the
cache control values
that you dictate in
your CDN configuration
based on specific mind types.
And those mine types are
listed here on our slide.
The second component
we want to talk about
within Flexible Cache Control
is Header Manipulation.
And within Header
Manipulation, there
are a couple of
different use cases
that will be addressed
with this release.
The first one is the ability to
add downstream response headers
to the end user client.
This is helpful for things
like adding course header
values, which can be important
for or streamed objects,
or JavaScript objects, that
require additional helper
module, helper directives to
allow the browser to leverage
the particular object
that is being delivered.
The next capability within
the Header Manipulation bucket
is the ability to bypass a
cache on a header request.
And this can be
helpful to distinguish
between an authorized
and an unauthorized user.
Or it could be used
to determine things
like a logged in or
a logged in user.
So for example, you might
want to have a cached page
experience for
unauthenticated users.
In the case where you have a
more personalized experience
and the user actually
is authenticated,
you might want to
bypass the cache
and go directly to the
origin for a more customized
experience.
Deliver it up from
the origin itself.
The third use case under
the Header Manipulation
is the ability to restrict the
methods that are being used.
So by default, Google is going
to allow all different method
types to get funneled into
your origin web server.
With this new capability out
of the Flexible Cache Control,
we now have the ability to
be more prescriptive in terms
of what feature
method types that we
want to allow into the origin.
The benefit here is that this
will allow you to tighten up
your security policy.
So for example, if your website
doesn't accept post requests,
then we can specifically deny
post requests on the CDN Edge,
rather than funneling those
requests all the way back
to the origin where
potentially it
could be ripe for
vulnerability or exploitation.
The other part of this,
when we talk about things
like adding course
headers, it helps
enrich the client
requests experience
so that we can take advantage
of capabilities that
are native inside the browser.
Such as cores capabilities.
The third extension of
the Flexible Cache Control
is error handling.
Prior to the release of Flexible
Cache Control and the error
handling module, the
Cloud CDN platform
would pass through
whatever error
that was handed to
it from the origin.
And this kind of
manifested itself
in reduced site availability.
We're making
modifications to the way
that Cloud CDN behaves to
enhance your site availability.
The fist extension of that
is with negative caching.
So specifically, if you
advertise certain HTTP status
codes from your origin,
we have the ability
to actually cache those requests
to help buffer your origin
from these responses.
The second extension
specifically
around Error Handling, is the
ability to serve stale content.
So by default, when
an end user request
is made to the Cloud
CDN Edge, we're
going to make a
determination if we have
that content we'll serve it.
If we don't have that content,
but we have the object sitting
in cache, we're going to
consult with the origin
for revalidation of that object.
Of whether or not
we can continue
to serve that out of our cache.
In the event that the
origin isn't available,
we would in the past serve
up an error response.
With this new capability,
we now have the ability
to serve that stale content
rather than serving up
the error page.
So this is going to, again,
help increase your website
availability.
But it also helps buffer your
origin at times of high load.
From an integration perspective,
some helpful tips to share
with you.
So first off, by default
Google will be turning
on serving of stale content.
By default. The TTL
default value is one day.
So in the event where we have
an object in our edge cache
and we can't revalidate
it with the origin,
the default posture
will be to serve out
stale, rather than serving
up an error message.
Subsequently, the
negative caching
will be an opt in feature, where
it will be available to you,
but you must elect to configure
and turn that behavior
on in your configuration set.
That negative caching will
not be enabled by default.
In our next level
of enhancements
that I would like
to discuss with
you is around
Platform Enhancements.
And the first feature
we'll want to highlight
is Resource Coalescing.
With Resource Coalescing
this helps, particularly
with things like
live streaming, when
we have lots of requests all
looking for the same object.
In the past each request
would be treated individually.
With Resource
Coalescing, or sometimes
called request collapsing,
we have the ability
to fulfill that request
for multiple edge requests
from a single request, and share
out that response to the edge
server, rather than making a
lots of individual requests.
This helps with content
offload from the origin,
and also helps with content
scaling for high volume events.
The next platform enhancement
that I want to talk to you
about is TCP Enhancements.
So as part of our recurring
theme of always improving
our time to first byte,
and also improving
our throughput
response rates, we
are making
modifications to the way
that Cloud CDN will interact
with the end user client.
All of this is invisible
to the end user.
All of this is invisible to
you, from a configuration
standpoint.
It just magically
will get better.
Specifically, on the
TCP Enhancements,
we're making modifications
to our throughput,
but we're also making
enhancements to our pacing.
So today we're using pacing
that leverages BBR, for example.
One of the things
that we're looking
at adding into the platform
in the second semester
is looking at adding
the BBR version two.
Again, another advancement
coming from Google.
The next item that I want to
talk to you about is HTTP/3.
So today we support QUIC,
more specifically gQUIC.
And this can be found
already embedded
and it's already enabled on
Chrome and the latest Firefox
browsers today.
And this is now enabled
on your platform
that you can enable and opt
in to, in your Cloud CDN
configuration.
But we're not stopping there.
We are now going to be extending
the QUIC platform from gQUIC
and we're transforming
that to iQUIC,
which is now the new standard
for the QUIC protocol.
The iQUIC is kind of
a precursor of sorts
to the HTTP/3 protocol.
And as we start to rollout
iQUIC and the HTTP/3 protocol
to the entire Cloud CDN
fleet, Cloud CDN customers
will automatically
have the ability
to leverage this new protocol.
The benefit of using
the HTTP/3 protocol
is going to improve not only
your time to first byte,
but also improve the client
performance and stability
for end user
clients, particularly
on unstable networks.
So in summary, the
Cloud CDN platform
is making a lot of
investment in our platform,
not only in terms of enhancing
and adding new features
and functionality to
the Cloud CDN platform,
but we're also looking
at extending our industry
leading performance
characteristics
and capabilities.
Likewise, we're also making
additional investments
in Cloud CDN to revamp
the user experience.
So it's going to become
easier and a more enriching
environment for you to use
Cloud CDN without having to go
to multiple different screens.
And with that, I
want to thank you
for attending my
presentation today,
and I welcome to see you
on a future presentation.